good afternoon
i'm here today with alberta's chief
medical officer of health dr hinshaw to
provide an update on the coveted
closely and there are frustrations when
we have this kind of technical issue we
have a team of dedicated professionals
who work hard on that data
not just the daily case numbers but also
the extensive dashboard application that
has aggregate data
chart
graphs on vaccines severe outcomes
characteristics of this virus and more
alberta reports some of the best
information of any jurisdiction in the
country
but the pandemic is straining every part
of our response including our reporting
system
we'll continue to work to limit delays
and resolve issues with reporting as
they arise
but have data so let's review it
currently the number of lab confirmed
active cases sits at 51 157
of course we know that due to the
current eligibility for pcr testing and
expanded availability of rapid tests the
actual number is much higher
what is less likely to be impacted by
the testing criteria is our positivity
rate which is currently at 43 percent
this is still high but our average
positivity has not risen since january
the 6th
we are also monitoring the level of
covet virus in wastewater across the
province
in most of the centers we're monitoring
covet 19 levels in our wastewater are
starting to drop in some cases such as
in edmonton copenhagen levels in the
wastewater there have been dropping for
nearly two weeks
taken together
these are early positive signs that
transmission and new cases may be
slowing
however
even though there are early indications
are coming down
our hospitalizations are continuing to
increase
today there are
1377 people in hospital who have tested
positive for covet 19 which is an
increase of about 30 percent over the
past week
as in previous waves hospital emissions
will lag behind cases
so there's no discrepancy in the fact
that cases seem to be starting to be
going down
while emissions at the same time are
rising
it means
i hope
we're at a turning point in the current
wave and we can start to see the end of
it
but make no mistake
the coming weeks are going to be the
toughest yet
for many albertans
and for the people working in core
inpatient units in our hospitals
but admissions follow cases
once we see a sustained drop in cases
we can expect to be on the downslope in
admissions within a few weeks
now over the last seven days an average
of fifty eight point six percent of new
non-icu admissions and sixty six point
one percent of new icu admissions are
directly due to covent 19.
the remainder are patients with covet 19
where covid is an incidental infection
unrelated to the emission or it's
unclear whether or not it's related
but as we said before
whether patients are in hospital to be
treated for covent or they just happen
to be infected we need to make sure that
these patients don't go on to affect
other patients or staff
our hospitals have additional care
protocols in place to prevent further
transmissions
those practices take time and resources
and add to the strain on our system
that's why as we announced last week
our government and ahs have activated
contingency plans to prepare for the
additional burden that omicron continues
to place on our acute care system
these contingency plans include
maximizing capacity with pandemic
response units
adjusting staffing
and establishing community covenant
clinics where appropriate
our hospitals are under strain
especially in the larger urban centers
staff are tired not just from the
current wave of cases
but from five waves over two years we
owe them a tremendous debt of gratitude
but i also want to be clear that the
health system is there for you if you
need it and it is safe
ahs is still doing around 90 percent of
normal surgery volume
now they may have to reduce more
but they'll do it in the most limited
way they can and work hard to avoid the
kind of reductions that we've seen in
previous waves
they have plans in place to manage the
patients in hospital today and over the
coming weeks
in fact as of today we're still within
the normal capacity of the non-icu units
that take the vast majority of coleman
patients that we're seeing with omicron
that's for the system overall
there are certainly some sites that are
already over 100 capacity where surge
spaces are in use and more will be used
as necessary in the coming days
the system is under strain that's no
question
but we can manage it thanks to the
dedication of our people and again i'd
like to take this opportunity to say
thank you to all health care workers
doctors and volunteers who are providing
the critical care needed by albertans
i'm also pleased to announce today
that the first shipments at paxlovan
pfizer's at home prescription coven 19
treatment are set to be available to
albertans starting january 31st
initially
3200 courses of treatment will
be available as another option in
addition to the antibody therapy we've
been using for the past several months
to help keep eligible individuals with
mild to moderate covid from experiencing
severe illness and ending up in hospital
paxilvid will be a second option for
some individuals and social vimab
remains available for albertans who may
benefit from treatment
i know there have been many questions
about this treatment since it was
approved by health canada last monday
and people are curious to know how it
can be assessed
our staff has been working through
implementation details in developing
guidance for clinicians and pharmacists
the short answer is it can and will be
accessible for albertans soon
the longer answer is that because there
is a limited supply and because it is a
medication that causes some side effects
only specific groups of albertans will
be eligible to get it
there's a process in place to make sure
those who need it the most will be first
in line
pax of it is a pill taken orally that is
available only with a prescription
treatment has to start within the first
five days of coven 19 symptoms
it is intended for use by individuals 18
and older who have specific medical
conditions or those who are unvaccinated
and 65 years of age and older
dr hinshaw will have more details on
these conditions in a few moments
in addition
to be eligible for paxolvid a patient
must have a pcr-confirmed coven-19
infection
due to such a limited initial supply the
drug will only be available at select
number of pharmacies in the province
by by prescription and after an
assessment by ahs health link
albertans are asked not to call
pharmacies or physician offices directly
we hope that this will change as supply
increases
but any expansion will be subject to the
federal government providing additional
doses
the use of therapy
therapeutic drugs is a promising next
step in our efforts to fight more
serious outcomes
such as hospitalization due to covet 19.
however we cannot rely solely on it
and the ones that will inevitably follow
to get us through this wave or any
future wave
which is why we continue to make
vaccines easily and conveniently
available across the entire province
on that note i am pleased to say that
alberta has received an additional
supply of pfizer approximately 500 000
doses this month
while we know that both mrna vaccines
are safe and effective i know that some
albertans have been waiting for pfizer
as they prefer to receive the same
vaccine for all three doses
so if you've been waiting it's here and
please book your appointment today
you can book an appointment online
through the alberta vaccine booking
system or by directly contacting your
local pharmacy
and if you live on a reserve you can
also contact your local public health
clinic
many pharmacies have doses available on
a walk-in basis so you can also try just
showing up if you prefer
this is true for all doses not just
boosters so if you're not yet fully
vaccinated you can get your first or
second dose today through most
pharmacies in alberta
getting fully vaccinated against
covenanting is our best defense against
this virus and our best way to help keep
our health system from being overwhelmed
in addition to getting fully vaccinated
i'd like to encourage alberta to
continue to follow health guidelines in
place
wear a mask when appropriate
and stay home if you're not feeling well
as i recently did
omicron is so prevalent in alberta right
now that even mild symptoms like runny
nose and slight cough could well be
coveted
because we never know just how far a
chain a transmission might reach
it's better to be safe than sore
so thank you for doing your part to
protect yourself
and reduce the strain on their health
care system
and thanks again to all our health care
professionals who are working so hard
and will be continue to work to provide
the healthcare service for albertans
through the coming next very challenging
weeks
i'll now invite dr hinshaw to the podium
to say a few words
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
i'd like to build on the minister's
remarks about our data issues yesterday
by saying i know that we have all come
to rely on the daily updates especially
the ones on mondays that tell us the
weekend numbers so it's frustrating for
everyone to have technical difficulties
get in the way of that
what may not be immediately apparent is
the complexity of the system required to
get the updates completed every weekday
and the many people who work hard behind
the scenes to make that happen
the numbers we post online rely on 10
different data systems with millions of
different data points cross-referenced
and quality checked every day
the infrastructure necessary for this to
go smoothly sometimes one of the
components has a technical issue
that has a ripple effect throughout the
whole system
our teams worked hard all day yesterday
to address the technical problems that
cropped up but unfortunately weren't
able to get all systems back up and
running until today
the dashboards will be updated today
with the usual content and i want to
thank albertans for their patience as we
continually strive to make a wide
variety of data points available
in as timely a way as possible
i also want to say how much i appreciate
our amazing analytics and i.t teams and
how hard they have worked over the past
two years to ensure that we are able to
provide robust and timely data to the
public
speaking of data over the past couple of
weeks we have had to modify our
reporting which has included schools
today i have an update provided by
alberta education
as of january 24th 18 of the more than 2
500 schools in alberta have shifted to
temporary at home learning to address
operational challenges
five of the eighteen have less than
forty students total
this means that less than one percent of
schools are on temporary at-home
learning
all requests from schools to shift to
at-home learning have been approved
alberta education will continue to work
with school authorities on shifts to
at-home learning
school authorities continue to have the
flexibility to shift a class or an
individual grade to short-term at-home
learning to address operational
challenges at school if needed
turning to today's numbers
over the last 24 hours we have
identified
2722 new cases of covid19
and completed about
6700 tests
the positivity rate is about 42.8
sadly 13 new deaths have been reported
to alberta health over the past 24 hours
again i ask all of us to remember that
each of these numbers and each number in
hospital or icu reporting is a person
covid continues to have a significant
impact and i extend my sympathies to
anyone who has lost a loved one to covid
or any other cause in the recent weeks
as the minister has announced there is
now a new option to treat covid19 after
someone has been infected
in addition to the monoclonal antibody
we have been able to offer to albertans
for several months
last week health canada approved
paxlovid a drug that can treat mild to
moderate cases of covid19
as you heard starting monday january
31st we will be able to offer it to a
limited group of albertans
we have established the current
eligibility criteria to ensure that
those who are most at risk and who have
no contraindications are able to access
this treatment in a timely manner
helping to reduce the risk of covid
progressing to a more serious stage
the criteria include immunocompromised
individuals age 18 and over regardless
of their vaccination status who have
received transplants who are cancer
patients and have received chemotherapy
or another immunosuppressive treatment
in the past two years
or who have an inflammatory condition
that they are being treated for such as
rheumatoid arthritis lupus or
inflammatory bowel disease
paxlovid will also be a possible option
for albertans who are unvaccinated and
over the age of 65
or age 18 or older with a pre-existing
health condition such as diabetes
obesity chronic kidney disease or
obstructive pulmonary disease or
congestive heart failure
in addition to meeting one of the
criteria i have just mentioned
individuals must have a confirmed case
of covid and be within five days of when
they first experienced covid19 symptoms
individuals who meet these criteria will
be prompted to contact healthlink when
they receive their positive results for
an initial evaluation of eligibility
those who are potentially eligible will
then be referred to a clinician with
training and options for early covert
treatment both monoclonal antibodies and
paxlovit
as paxlovid medication can cause side
effects it will be available only by
prescription after an assessment by
these clinicians who can determine which
of the treatment options would be
recommended for the patient
i know that there may be many albertans
who wish to access paxlovit or
sotrovamab the other currently approved
covid19 treatment
but supplies are limited at this time
these treatments have marginal benefit
for individuals at low risk of
hospitalization and there are also risks
of inducing antiviral resistance to
covid19
if paxlovit is used improperly
this is why we are starting the use of
this medication with a centralized
system to ensure that the benefits of
its use outweigh the risks
as we learn more we will be able to
evaluate the data and update eligibility
criteria as appropriate
in the future we will also be
transitioning to a broader community
prescription approach but this will take
time
for now please do not call pharmacies or
physicians directly to get a
prescription for paxlovid as they will
be unable to give it to you
and as the saying goes an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure
while paxlovit is a new secondary option
to prevent mild or moderate cases of
covid19 from progressing to severe
disease
it bears repeating that it is not a
substitute for vaccination
vaccination is the most effective way to
prevent severe cases of covid19
and reduce the risks that come with
getting infected
unfortunately we cannot yet perfectly
predict if any individual will have
covid19
and have only a week-long experience
with mild symptoms or
if there's long coverage or severe
symptoms that result
what we do know is that vaccines can
protect us from the worst impacts of
covid19
we also know that covid19 vaccines that
we get as individuals can reach beyond
us to help protect those who cannot be
vaccinated themselves
a recent analysis of our data shows that
adult vaccination affects the chances of
very young children getting infected
with covid19
children in households where no adults
have been vaccinated have a one and a
half times greater chance of being
hospitalized with covid19
compared to children in households where
all adults are fully vaccinated
this data supports the fact that
vaccination remains the best way to
prevent severe outcomes such as
hospitalization due to covet 19 not only
for ourselves but also for our
households
this is why like the minister i continue
to encourage albertans to get every
vaccine dose that they are eligible for
some may wonder if they have had coveted
recently or that they should still get
their booster dose now
i think it is reasonable for those who
have had a recent confirmed case of
covid19
to wait a few months before getting a
booster although all available data
indicates there is no significant risk
of harm in receiving a vaccine once
recovered from a covet infection
for those who have just felt ill and
have not been tested to know if they
have coveted or not
i would recommend getting a booster once
you have recovered as there are other
viruses circulating that may have been
the cause of the illness
third doses help not just the person
receiving it but those around you as
well as doses limit the chance of
getting covered and spreading the
infection to others
today i also want to comment on a remark
i made last week about hospitalizations
in five to eleven-year-olds who had a
single dose of vaccine
i have gone back to our data to ensure
that i have the most recent information
on this
and i can tell you that we have had six
hospitalizations in those in this age
group who have had one dose
this is compared with 75
hospitalizations in the last 120 days
in those who have had no doses in this
age group
many children in this age group are
coming due for their second doses now
and i encourage parents to access this
protection for their children and their
families
in addition i would like to remind
albertans that we always have a choice
to do the right thing for ourselves and
for others
i know that as we see numbers rise and
fall it is easy to become desensitized
and that as we have vaccines and new
treatments available it may seem like we
no longer need to rely on measures that
have helped us get to this point
but it is important that we continue to
protect ourselves and others by using
all the tools at our disposal
whether it's masking whenever we're
indoors in a public place
distancing from others when possible or
reducing our social contacts by at least
half
if we continue to use all of these
measures in tandem along with vaccines
we will be able to reduce transmission
and reduce the impacts and the strain on
our health care providers
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thank you minister copping and thank you
dr hinshaw for your comments
now i'd like to open the floor to
questions from media we have a few
minutes for that so operator would you
please let the first caller through
thanks for taking my call
uh dr hinch i want to ask you about um
masking in the school
there's a new report out by an american
group of physicians and scientists
uh called urgency of normal it's a group
of people who want who are pushing for
the lives of our kids to return to
normal and they're questioning the
efficacy and the use of
masking policies in schools
um saying that these studies don't show
any defined benefit for the latest
studies don't show that
and that it's time to get rid of them
on what science would you say our
masking policy is based on in alberta
in alberta we have looked at the
available evidence with respect to the
impacts of masking in community and
again looking at
settings where there have been a small
number of community randomized
controlled trials done that looked at
the impact of medical masks in
particular
and those are the the medical grade
surgical type masks that showed
reductions in infection rates
we've also looked at our own data with
respect to
in the fall where we had masking in
some schools and not in others we did
observe
differences in outbreaks in schools
where masking was not in use as opposed
to schools that it was in use
so we have that observational data
available from our own experience in the
fall
i would say that all of us are very keen
to get back to more of a normal
situation for ourselves and our children
but we also know that covert 19 is still
a threat that transmission is still high
and that while children and especially
kids in the
younger age group that 5 to 11 group are
at individual lower risk of severe
outcomes that risk is not zero and those
kids can also take
covid19 if they get infected home to
their families so unfortunately
we
must continue to use the interventions
that we know have an impact and
get through this current wave before we
can consider how we can
cautiously make decisions that
help us get back to more of a normal
approach while at the same time not
putting people's health at jeopardy with
direct covet impacts
thank you dr hinshaw david do you have
follow-up
yes dr hincher in the past you've talked
about children having a risk from covid
which is i i think
i don't think i'm putting words in your
mouth similar to the flu
um
is that changed with omicron is the risk
has have we seen a greater risk for
children
than in the past
the
risk of severe outcomes does vary a
little bit by the specific variant so we
know that with omicron the individual
risk
seems to be lower than the risk from
delta having said that when the
transmission of any variant is extremely
high
we can see increased numbers of kids
needing hospital care the thing that is
significantly different between
influenza and kovid
is the risk that it poses for older
people and the fact that children can
unfortunately
introduce the virus back to households
or those who they're around
and we need to consider the
interventions for the benefit of our
entire communities
so with respect to to influenza again
in the case of omicron again that
individual risk
is quite low but we've also in the past
when we have influenza circulating we
have other
protections in place that don't cause
that same kind of significant severe
illness burden and those are the
differences that we're needing to
navigate right now
thank you dr hinchell operator can you
let our next caller through
rick bell calgary son
a good afternoon minister and uh dr
hinshaw a question for minister cropping
and i will have a follow-up
uh the main question is um
you've uh
spoken some pretty hopeful language
minister copping about what the future
will look like
and i'm not going to ask you for an
actual date or even something close to
an actual date of when
there could be a serious
uh lifting of restrictions because of
course you can't provide that date i
understand that there are a lot of
people
including even people who are your
colleagues on the united conservative
benches who would like to see
some of the major risk of restrictions
or major measures such as vaccine
passports or masks etc
uh to eventually be gone so let's look
at those more major uh measures like
vaccine passports and
masks
can you give us some sense
i know the hospital numbers have to go
down i've heard all that before but
basically
some sense
of some place on the calendar
where
at least we can look at
where that
will or will not happen or will happen i
should say
well thanks for the the question rick
and you're right in as you start out
your question i can't give you a date
because we don't know what's going to
happen i i am hopeful
uh that the number of cases uh are on on
the downslope um but as we said today
hospitalizations are continue to rise um
all going well we'll see those you know
in the next few weeks they'll start to
come down and i think the premier said
this before you know
you know we can start looking at
reducing restrictions once we see a
sustained trend and reduction in cases
and reduction in in hospitalizations i i
fully appreciate uh that that people are
tired uh we went from the fourth wave um
very modest uh changes to uh
restrictions uh and then we had to
increase them for the uh for uh to
manage through the fifth wave uh now
again i'm hopeful that uh uh where uh
the cases are cresting and and uh and
coming down the other side and we'll see
in a couple weeks uh that in our in our
hospitals but right now we need to
continue to focus on you know following
the uh the the the restrictions uh you
know staying home when you're sick we're
wearing masks getting boost your shots
to get through this see the hospital
numbers come down uh and then we can
take the the next step
follow up rick
yes and it's kind of a quickie two-part
follow-up to because i just want to
clarification on the first one and then
the follow-up the clarification is you
talk about you want to see a sustained
trend of hospitalizations going down
are we talking about
it could take three months two months
six months
five i mean just a ballpark of when you
are hoping just hoping that a sustained
trend is there
and today premier le go said about his
province that a lot of people in his
province are fed up they're fed up with
the restrictions
it's been 22 months let's bring your
lego what have you heard from people
here and what do you think the
prevailing mood
is of albertans with respect to
restrictions so if you could answer when
do you think that sustained trend of
hospitalizations is going to go down
and
do you what do you see as the prevailing
mood of albertans lagos says in quebec
a lot of people are fed up
what is the prevailing mood here
yeah so i appreciate you know i'm
hearing from people that it's been
incredibly challenging especially from
fourth wave straight into the in into
the fifth wave uh and people are tired
um we're still in the middle of the
fifth rate right now but there is light
at the end of the tunnel
in terms of timelines it's very
difficult to give that to you rick
we can look at other jurisdictions
around the world and see that the you
know numbers have come down and some of
them quite quickly
but again we'll be watching
other jurisdictions here in canada as
well uh very closely in ontario quebec
who are a little bit ahead of us uh what
they're doing and then you know gauge
ourselves accordingly
thank you minister copping operator can
you let through the next caller
thank you lisa mcgregor global edmonton
hi there there is a huge discrepancy in
the amount of rapid tests given out
to each province so much so that when
you do the math essentially it's four
in alberta per person you got 13 per
person in saskatchewan and even 10 per
person in nova scotia
and you even have people in saskatchewan
mailing
rapid tests to people in alberta because
they're so desperate for the test and
the feds confirmed
that before january
this was on the government
of each province to decide how much
they'd get and when so
my question to you is how do you explain
the management of that
especially because now
it's costing albertans more money out of
pockets because they're so desperate for
a test
a rapid testing program for
for employers uh and for
organizations um to be able to test
employees in in critical settings and
that program has been running uh all the
way like number of months last year we
opened up a public uh program in
december of
last year
started uh putting out more and more
tests uh
unfortunately the the federal government
as of january given the increased
demands even though we had backdated
orders from december
they base the federal government at that
point said given the demand across the
country uh indicated to us that they
were going to give it out on a per
population basis uh and be able to
provide the tests for us so you know
given given concerns of that and the
availability of tests as you know
we as a government uh in uh went forward
to uh buy an additional 10 million tests
uh ourselves uh and get them out so and
but there has been a challenge in some
of the supply chains uh over uh we sell
this over january some of the uh the
shipments were delayed uh but we are
getting those uh those out now but if
you want to explain the difference
between you know some of the the tests
the saskatchewan ran a a uh
a public system uh and
with public access to tests uh earlier
on uh than we did that may describe
explain some of it at this point in time
i know that the federal government is
distributing it on a per capita basis
and and our government is also going out
to purchase tests to get them in the
hands of albertans as quickly as
possible
and lisa do you have a follow-up
i do i think i just need clarification i
mean yes now moving forward it's per
capita but i'm talking beforehand
can you sit here and say that maybe the
government of alberta wasn't late to the
party or perhaps
underestimated how much albertans wanted
these free tests because
i mean regardless of programs
you've got a population in alberta
that's very different than saskatchewan
people in saskatchewan can still walk
into a clinic today and get a free test
no problem
so is there any responsibility in the
fact that
prior to january
our government didn't jump on board to
get those tests and now people are
having to pay 30 bucks 40 bucks 50 bucks
because they want to live their lives
and they they need a rapid test
yeah so we we did
uh
have rapid tests coming in for a uh for
a program
for employers and so that we can
actually test in a number of settings
and then we actually started our public
program in uh
in december um asked for additional uh
tests from the federal government
we didn't receive all of those and then
because of the concerns of that we went
out and uh and we we purchased uh over
10 million tests ourselves to be able to
get out to albertans again as i said
there's challenges in regards to supply
chains as a result
some of those didn't come out as early
in january but we have far more tests
that are coming out we'll be coming out
towards the end of this month
thank you minister copping operator can
you relate to the next question
thank you matt woodman ctv
hi there my question is for mr copping
um we heard that a patient died while
waiting for care at the emergency room
at the red deer hospital this weekend
apparently they were assessed and it was
determined their situation wasn't severe
enough for urgent care what is your
message to this family uh who was told
this when their loved one died
yeah so my my heart goes out uh to the
family and anyone who's passed away in
our in our system
i don't have all the details on this i
just i just heard about it i know that
uh ahs is investigating i understand
that some of the facts that that that
you have raised that they were triaged
and uh and brought into the into the
emergency department and then and sadly
passed away so i'm uh you know taking
this matter very seriously i've asked
ahs for a report and they're looking
into it at this point in time
thank you do a follow-up
i do um
healthcare workers tell us this is a
sign that staff are overwhelmed and the
system is stressed so what can be done
to stop this from happening again to
another alberta family
yeah i i understand that there's strain
on the system i can my my understanding
in terms of initial reports that you
know the emergency department uh in red
deer at that time was was uh was fully
staffed uh recognized that they're along
there are some long wait times so that
that person was
admitted um but but again
you know our focus and this is part of
the plan that we laid out last week uh
is to you know
provide uh additional surge capacity to
deal with with covid which is putting
strain on the system uh as indicated
we'll be opening up some uh pr prus uh
this week and then you know leveraging
is the staff as much as as much as
possible you know as dr you indicated
last week
we're bringing on board numbers of
nursing students we've hired
over the last two years hundreds of
nurses into the system we recognize this
is going to be a challenging time but
we're going to continue to focus to
provide the best care for alberta
patients as we get through it
thank you minister we have time for just
a few more questions operator can you
look through the next caller please
thank you joshua hall red deer news now
hi there my questions are for the
minister today
um this past sunday as was just alluded
to wait times at regular regional
hospital peaked at over 14 hours with an
average wait time of nearly four hours
over the weekend
local doctors and citizens have been
sounding the alarm over this
infrastructure deficit for years and
long before covid while funding for
hospital expansion has continued to be
kicked down the road with a business
case that's under review as we know
what commitment can you make minister to
central zone residents and doctors today
that you're doing all you can to see
that hospital expansion starts
construction as soon as possible
yeah so we we fully understand
um the need for increased infrastructure
within the central zone uh and red deer
and i can't and work is being done on
that i can tell you uh and i can't tell
anything uh i can't tell you anything
further um you know decisions will be
made over the coming weeks uh in terms
of what projects will will go ahead in
uh in the budget um but this i i we are
aware that there's a there's there's an
infrastructure deficit there and as you
indicated work has been ongoing in terms
of how do we address that
thank you minister and do you have a
follow-up
i do thanks um just to to go back to
that same subject uh you know one doctor
told us today that the pressure at the
hospital in red deer is extreme another
says the fact that expansion hasn't
happened yet means ultimately that
patients are receiving quote substandard
care
so when you hear these types of accounts
minister what does that make you think
about how several iterations of
government have failed to provide
the nearly half million albertans in the
central zone the level of healthcare
that they deserve
yeah so our our focus of our government
and ahs is provide you know equitable
health care across the the entire
province um we understand that there's
been a uh
uh
a request and and quite frankly a need
for uh infrastructure in in red deer um
you know i've had number of
conversations like that and again work
has been going ongoing in that regard
and we'll be able to say more
hopefully in uh in the coming weeks
thank you very much minister operator
can you look through our next caller
please
shane closing everything gp
good afternoon this question is for
minister copping uh we've received some
messages this week from people in the
peace region saying uh i guess they've
gone to an emergency room and were
unable to get the karen graham
previously they were potentially uh
taken to
edmonton on a medevac including one
woman who took her child there and
they said they couldn't help her
obviously this is a brand new hospital
uh what is the current situation at the
grand prix regional hospital here in
grand prairie and are you guys concerned
about hearing a story like that so every
time i hear a story that raises a
concern this is the first story that
i've heard that there was concerns and
ability of the new hospitals provide
to provide care so happy to look into
that
look into that further
thank you do you have a follow-up
yeah i'm just wondering too uh just
obviously there the new hospital now
here is built and up and running uh
given uh september saw a pretty uh
pr pretty tough uh or i guess a grim
look here for the grand prairie region
just in terms of how copic 19 was
hitting the uh qe2 hospital obviously
that's now gone so just wondering how
was the grand prix regional hospital
this time around coping with the amount
of corporate 19 patients
yeah my and i don't have the exact data
and staff can follow up with you on that
my understanding is that the uh
um when when we take a look at across
the province uh the sites that are the
most impacted uh are primarily in
calgary uh edmonton and uh and you
actually see some of that in in red deer
as well uh in grand prairie my
understanding is that's not as impacted
but i'll let staff follow up in terms of
the the exact percentage of capacity on
our emergency departments there
thank you very much minister we have
time for one more question operator
hewlett through our final caller please
andrea williams cbc
hi my questions for minister copping i
don't know if that was mentioned in the
press conference so i apologize if
you said it already but i wanted to know
how much of the how much
boxes or pills of passovid
have we received so far and what's the
plan uh to
receive more
yeah there are
3200 uh
courses of treatment we have received
i've been in conversations with my
colleagues across government across the
country and the and the federal
government
we've received them already there's a
plan to receive more in february we
don't have the exact numbers or the
exact date yet but we're pressing the
federal government to
provide
more courses of treatment because we
believe that this can be a another tool
in the toolkit to reduce the impact on
our hospitals and and the impact on
alberts
thank you minister and andrea do you
have a follow-up question
uh no all the questions have been asked
thank you thank you very much to all of
our callers today and to mr copping and
dr hinshaw
thank you